[Music]
in 1972 Thomas Sankara was swept into a
revolution for a country not his own
hailing from the West African nation of
Burkina Faso then known as Upper Volta
the 22 year old soldier had traveled to
Madagascar to study at their military
academy but upon arriving he found a
nation in conflict local revolutionaries
sought to wrest control of Madagascar
from France's lingering colonial rule
these protestors inspired Sankara to
read works by socialist leaders like
Karl Marx and seek wisdom from military
strategy when he returned to Upper Volta
in 1973 son Carl was determined to free
his country from its colonial legacy
born in 1949 Sankara was raised in a
relatively privileged household as the
third of ten children his parents wanted
him to be a priest but like many of his
peers
Sankara saw the military as the perfect
institution to rid Upper Volta of
corruption after returning from
Madagascar he became famous for his
charisma and transparent oratory 'el
style but he was less popular with the
reigning government led by president
jean-baptiste WA drago this
administration came to power in the
third consecutive coup d'etat in Upper
Volta 'he's recent history the
administration's policies were a far cry
from the sweeping changes Sankara
proposed but by 1981 sin Cara's
popularity won out earning him a role in
what rago's government nicknamed
Africa's Che Guevara Sankara rapidly
rose through the ranks and within two
years he was appointed prime minister in
his new role he delivered rallying
speeches to impoverished communities
women and young people he even tried to
persuade other governments to form
alliances based on their shared colonial
legacy but what Drago and his advisers
felt threatened by son Cara's new
position they thought his communist
beliefs would harm alliances with
capitalist countries and just months
after becoming Prime Minister hua
Drago's administration forced Ankara
from the job and placed him on house
arrest
little did the president know this act
would fuel up or vultus fourth coup
d'etat in 17 years
civilian protests ensued around the
capital and the government ground to a
halt while Sankara tried to negotiate a
peaceful transition during this time
blaze Campari sin Cara's friend and
fellow former soldier foiled another
coup that included an attempt on son
Cara's life eventually well Drago
resigned without further violence and on
August 4th 1983 Thomas Sankara became
the new president of Upper Volta finally
in charge some car launched an ambitious
programme for social and economic change
as one of his first agenda items he
renamed the country from its French
colonial title Abra Volta to Burkina
Faso which translates to land of a
bright men over the next four years he
established a nationwide literacy
campaign ordered the planting of over 10
million trees and composed a new
national anthem all while cutting down
inflated government employees salaries
but perhaps the most unique element of
song Cara's revolution was his
dedication to gender equality he
cultivated a movement for women's
liberation out long forced marriages
polygamy and genital mutilation he was
the first African leader to appoint
women to key political positions and
actively recruit them to the military
however some cara socialist policies
were met with much resistance many
students and elites believed his
economic plans would alienate burkina
faso from its capitalist peers his
crackdown on the misuse of public funds
turned government officials against him
as well after four years what began as
an empowering revolution had isolated
many influential Burkina Bay but Sankara
was not ready to yield his power
he executed increasingly authoritarian
actions including banning trade unions
and the Free Press eventually his
autocratic tendencies turned even his
closest friends against him on October
15th 1987 son Cara was conducting a
meeting when a group of assailants
swarmed his headquarters son Cara was
assassinated in the attack and many
believe the raid was ordered by his
friend Blaise campare
though his legacy is complicated many of
son Cara's policies have proven
themselves to be ahead of their time in
the past decade
Burkina Bay Youth have celebrated sin
Cara's political philosophy and nearby
countries like Ghana have even adopted
some Cara's economic models on March 2nd
2019 a statue of son Cara was erected in
Burkina Faso's capital establishing his
place as an icon of revolution for his
country and throughout the world not all
revolutionaries are politicians or
soldiers for an inspiring tale of secret
student resistance in Nazi Germany check
out our video on the white rose or take
a closer look at the stirring poetry of
revolutionary and romantic Pablo Neruda
[Music]